au soir d'abord un mot sur la dernière
émission sur la nuit des longs couteaux
vous avez été une fois de plus très très
nombreux à m'écrire
merci mais beaucoup de lettres me
demandent de leur indiquer les lectures
sur ce thème et ça c'est une chose qui
me fait beaucoup de plaisir parce que
j'ai toujours soutenu que la télévision
loin d'empêcher de lire et d très
souvent à lire alors je peux vous
conseiller
naturellement le grand livre de haut
william sheller ascension et chute du
troisième reich qui couvre toute la
période et sur le sujet déterminé
proprement dit le livre de max gallo
l'excellent livre de max gallo la nuit
des longs couteaux chez robert laffont
mais ce soir nous sommes très loin de la
nuit des longs couteaux puisque
l'histoire que je vais vous raconter
comment serait exactement le 20 janvier
1827 à janvier j'ai naturellement la
veille du 21ème sur la pallice nous le
dirai mais c'est surtout l'anniversaire
le 21 justement le 21 janvier de la mort
de louis saez et là nous sommes en
pleine restauration
on a un culte pour louis saez et à saint
denis il ya une messe solennelle ou
assiste la famille royale et tous les
dignitaires du royaume il ya dans le
cortège qui vient sortir de la basilique
les grandes orgues vous imaginez la
scène la foule regroupée et dans le
cortège
le vieux prince de talent oui il est là
naturellement en grand uniforme avec
toutes ses décorations avançant en
claudiquant sur sa canne l'homme de
toutes les palinodies l'homme de tous
les serments vous savez qu'il a prêté en
tout 13 serment dans sa vie à des
régimes différente cette même pas mal
c'est un record qui n'a pas été battu et
talent qui pour le moment est fidèle à
la restauration après avoir été fidèle à
la première monarchie puis
la révolution puis au directoire puis au
consulat puis à l' empire puis à louis
xviii talent rang s'avance très gai et
alors delà de la foule un homme sort de
grande taille les très énergique
il est vêtu de noir il porte simplement
sur ce noir la légion d'honneur
un point rouge il fend la foule
ce avance à grandes enjambées vers
talent est là tout à coup lui lance une
gifle et voilà talent qui tombe parce
que la gifle a vraiment été forte
on le relève est cet homme qui n'a
jamais manqué de présence d'esprit dit
gracieusement voilà à fameux coup de
poing il préfère ne pas parler de gifles
naturellement on a arrêté l'homme on l'a
conduit à la police et là il s'est
présenté jacques mari armand de geri
marquis de maubeuge et oui voilà le nom
prononcé pour la première fois ce soit
le nom du héros de l'aventuré que je
vais vous conter et ses membres et il
s'explique
on est dimanche à pourquoi avez vous
fait ça enfin giflé ce vieillard et dit
bien oui je n'ai qu'un regret c'est de
ne pas lui avoir craché au visage
c'est très aimable comme vous voyez et
il s'explique
et oui parce que cet homme là m'a gâché
la vie
un jour il m'a fait venir chez lui
c'était en 1814 et tous mes valeurs ont
commencé parce que ce jour là monsieur
le talent rend ma demander d'assassiner
napoléon mettez vous à la place du
commissaire de police qui écoute ça
c'est probablement la déclaration la
plus fantastique qu'il ait jamais
entendu de toute sa vie quoi on avait
demandé à ce marquis de maubreuil de
tuer la pole et en 1814 et qui le lui
avait demandé
tall rampe
on a des hommes les plus illustres de
l'enppi sinon l'un des plus respectés sa
possible et l'homme confiant je jure
oui talent m'a demandé de tuer la pole
alors est ce que c'est vrai et c'est
alors on a vraiment demandé à quelqu'un
de tuer napoléon comment pourquoi dans
quelles conditions
pour répondre à cette question il faut
que fassions un saut en arrière et que
nous nous retrouvions à nantes
très exactement en 1802 en 1802 où un
jeune homme de 18 ans vient d'arriver en
ténue de lieutenant de vaisseau il fait
une entrée sensationnel dans dans la
ville le postillon de sa voiture pour
une raison pour une outre n'avait pas
voulu rentrer dans la ville les puits
c'est lui qui était s'était assis sur le
siège
il avait pris les rênes et fouette
cocher il était entré deux bouts dans
cette voiture au grand galop et tout le
monde s'était écrié qu'est ce que c'est
ce lieutenant de vaisseau bien c'est le
temps de vaisseau c'était tout
simplement le frère cadet de napoléon
le jeune jérôme bonaparte savais que
tout ce qui touche à l'histoire de
napoléon par est un roman lui-même a dit
qu'elle remonte ma vie leur
naturellement toute la vie de ses
proches est aussi un roman ce petit
jérôme était arrivé quelques années plus
tôt avec sa mère madame laetitia ses
soeurs ses frères à marseille fuyant la
corse c'était un petit garçon et là on
l'avait connu la pire misère on l'avait
vécue par exemple à marseille avec des
bonds de pain se comptent donner aux
patriotes nécessiteux et voilà que par
miracle ou plutôt par un miracle qui
s'appelait la peau les os tout avait
changé
et quand le général bonaparte était
devenu premier consul fatalement son
jeune frère était devenu comme une sorte
de prince cadet l'argent coulait entre
ses mains il n'aimait que le plaisir les
filles le vin les amis ça faisait
beaucoup de bruit dans paris ce jeune
jérôme un peu trop haut bonaparte alors
il avait eu l'idée pourquoi l'un des
bonaparte ne serait-il pas marin d'en
faire un lieu de vie
oh et de l'envoyer à nantes pour
s'embarquer sur le navire l'épervier
mais voilà le navire n'était pas prêt et
jérôme est resté pendant deux mois très
exactement à nantes
et là il a purement et simplement
révolutionner nantes toute la jeunesse
dorée s'était rallié à lui jamais on l'a
vu à nantes on n'a peut être jamais revu
depuis
pardon pour les nantais et parmi cette
jeunesse il y avait un garçon de 19 ans
voyait à peu près l'âge de jérôme qui
était le jeune marquis de maubreuil ah
le voilà on l'aurait trop nombreuses
vieilles familles vendéennes très riche
il est né au château de maubreuil
pendant la révolution la famille a
émigré on l'a emmené en allemagne mais
la grand mère était resté sur place et
l'a réclamé son petit fils qu'elle
adorait alors on l'envoyait pratiquement
par la poste petit garçon était tout
petit et on l'envoyait à à francfort on
la donnait un évolution qu'il l'a oublié
dans une auberge en fin d'étape en étape
il est arrivé confié à de bonnes âmes
jusqu'à maubreuil hélas à 12 ans il
s'est lancé dans la chouette on peut
dire que toute son enfance son
adolescence s'est passé dans le bocage
vendéen dans le maquis vendéens à faire
le coup de feu contre les républicains
il s'est engagé à fond il s'est battu
bien battue jusqu'à la pacification de
la vendée alors là la guerre était finie
il a repris possession de son château de
sa fortune de sa fortune qui était
intacte parce que la grand mère qui
n'avait pas eu qu'il y avait eu au
contraire la bonne idée de ne pas
émigrer avait permis justement qu'on ne
saisissent pas les biens des mots breuil
il était là la tête de cet énorme
fortune près à la dépense et et c'est là
qu'il a connu géant donc deux mois de
gaieté de folles grit et d'amusement de
plaisir et puis enfin jérôme s'embarque
et le jeune maubreuil retourne à son
angle
il va bien faire quelques études à paris
mais enfin il n'est pas fait pour les
études
il revient maubreuil
et puis c'est la fabuleuse histoire
celle empire c'est la pole et aux
empereurs c'est le vainqueur de l'europe
c'est l'homme qui distribue les royaumes
à ses frais et en 1807 napoléon créé
pour jérôme qui a 25 ans à royaux en
allemagne le royaume de westphalie dans
la capitale et cassel jérôme qui est
posée la charmante catherine de würth
imbert la fille du roi du lupin berguois
aussi ça fait partie du roman de
l'épopée les princesses des anciennes
familles sally office du petit avocats
corses et à cassel au château de wilhem
ce qu'ils deviennent napoléon eux
pourquoi pas géraud va transposer ses
habitudes de bonne vie d'allégresse de
joie jamais probablement ne s'est amusé
en allemagne on arrive de partout il
nomme des chamberland par dizaines des
chanceliers des d un bibliothécaire et
pourtant il n'a aucun livre au château
en tirent des feux d'artifice auprès
desquels ceux de parry sound et feu
d'artifice de chef lieu de canton on
ordonne des chasses à courre qui
éclipsent totalement à la fois
rambouillet chambord et fontainebleau et
compiègne c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire de fabuleux que la vie
à cassel et le bruit le bruit en arrive
jusqu'à maubreuil et oui dans sa vendée
et là il pense à son vieil ami jérôme à
ces deux mois de franche camaraderie
cédiez pourquoi n'y restent pas le
rejoint et libre il est reçu à bras
ouverts et jérôme le fait immédiatement
pourquoi pas écuyer la reine et capite
tout irait bien
mob rail est fait pour être le commensal
de jérôme il l'a déjà prouvé le prouve
de nouveau le roi lui adore sa femme et
il a quand même sa maîtresse qui la
répartie géographiquement dans des
régions
différentes de son château pour pas trop
compliquer les choses
l'ennui c'est que maubreuil trouve l'une
de ses maîtresses à sombre elle
s'appelle blanche elle est ravissante
jérôme l'a enlevée en l'italie elle est
mariée à un certain la flèche
il a enlevé la flèche en même temps
parce que mon dieu il trouve ça très
bien et la flèche est d'ailleurs devenu
compte immédiatement mais blanche semble
avoir le coeur innombrables parce
qu'elle est non seulement mariée à ce
compte
elle est la maîtresse du roi elle
accueille avec joie maubreuil qui
devient son amant mais elle a également
encore un autre amant qui est à comines
ministère un français qui s'appelle la
scène vos breuil c'est très bien en ce
qui le concerne qu'il trompe jérôme mais
il ne sait pas que l'acer lui le tronc
qui va le savoir il entre un jour dans
la chambre de blanche et trouve la serre
et blanche dans une tenue et une
situation qui ne laisse vraiment aucun
doute blanche va essayer de s'excuser va
dire je soignais lasserre qui avait mal
à la gorge
mais comme ils sentent absolument nu
comme un ver tous les deux évidemment
maubreuil a du mal à le croire alors
c'est un homme violent
il a une cravache il se met à cingler de
coups de cravache le malheureux lasserre
qui s'en va en hurlant ayant à peine le
temps de revêtir un vêtement il singles
de la même manière les blanches des
pôles de blanche et elle s'enfuit ayant
également velopper sa nudité d'un âge
quelconque tout ça court dans les
couloirs de ville m e 2 e pardon et vous
imaginez le score on arrête maubreuil on
lui dit mais non arrêtez vous lé en
l'immobilisme et enfin le mal est fait
le roi est informé apprend en même temps
qu'il ait trompé et en plus par son
meilleur ami et qui trouve ça
extrêmement désagréable
mettez-vous à sa place mais il est roi
c'est davantage quelquefois alors il
nomme sur-le-champ maubreuil capitaine
dans l'armée westphalienne qui va aller
faire la campagne d'espagne
l'espagne est très loin au breuil
furieux 120 ha
le temps avant de partir de rédiger une
épître à blanche où il se moque de la
cour laisse malienne c'est un libelle
qu'ont publié qui fâchent beaucoup
jérôme jérôme voilà maubeuge en espagne
c'est la guerre d'espagne la guerre
difficile où napoléon s'est enlisé mme
aubry ici bas très bien ici bas très
bien parce que quand la campagne
s'achève du moins pour lui pour les
westphalien et bien il reçoit l'une des
trois légion d'honneur ce n est pas
beaucoup que napoléon attribue au
festival voilà en france on peut
naturellement pas rentrer en westphalie
alors ils sollicitent d'être capitaine
dans l'armée française grade qu'il avait
dans l'armée westphalienne on le lui
refuse probablement l'histoire de
blanche de l'épître à blanche et est
elle parvenue à l'apollon aux oreilles
de napoléon et napoléon ne souhaitait
pas donner un grade amoureux le voilà
réduit à la vie civile que faire il est
toujours aussi riche mais l oisiveté va
le conduire à de très mauvais calcul
étant riche il souhaite devenir plus
riche en coups et il place toute sa
fortune mais oui toute sa fortune dans
une affaire de fourniture de grains pour
l'armée l'espagne et s'associe
d'ailleurs avec un hollandais qui est un
tout petit peu curieux pour l'espagne
mais juste à ce moment là napoléon qui a
à se plaindre des fournisseurs qui se
sont enrichis d'une manière fabuleuse et
malhonnête casse d'un trait de plume
tous les marchés qui avaient été signés
et voilà maubreuil littéralement ruiné
et sans recours sans appel cet homme est
aux abois
il est couvert de dettes les créanciers
asahi son domicile il est obligé d'en
prendre un second elle-même à troisième
de manière à ce que les créanciers ne le
trouve pas quand ils viennent le
chercher pour le forcer à p on arrive
ainsi à l'année 1814 et c'est une année
qui évite naturellement bien les
commentaires vous savez que c'est dans
l'année
du 31 décembre 1813 au 1er janvier 1814
que les armées ennemies sont entrées en
france
on les avait pas vus depuis longtemps
les ennemis mais après la défaite de
russie après la désastreuse campagne
d'allemagne
eh bien c'était la campagne de france
qui commençait cette campagne de france
pendant laquelle napoléon à la tête de
ses troupes allaient accomplir des
prodiges c'est peut-être sa plus belle
quand mais l'infériorité numérique des
français face aux prussiens aux anglais
russes aux autrichiens au suédois aux
bavarois aux accents et à d'autres
l'infériorité numérique est écrasante et
de victoire en victoire parce que
napoléon remportent des victoires il est
acculé à la défaite
mme aubry est bien membré ce conduit
bien en janvier 1814 il offre même à
napoléon d'aller en bretagne la de
requérir des volontaires de former une
sorte de corps francs et d'aller
batailler sur les arrières des ennemis
nous n'avons pas à sa lettre le fait
qu'on lui réponde pas le dpic beaucoup
le vexe et la lamelle nar pensé à ses
malheurs mais oui les ruiner et au fond
si l'héroïne et c'est la faute à
bonaparte
cet homme qui avait servi l' empire qui
s'était rallié cet homme glisse de plus
en plus vers les passions de son enfance
et sa jeunesse vers le temps où lé dans
le maquis vendéen il tirait il tirait au
nom du roi et disons le sans royalisme
augmente à mesure que les ennemis de la
france approche de paris parce que à
mesure qu'ils approchent de paris on
peut se dire que l'étoile de la pole et
on s'obscurcit et qu'elle va mourir
bientôt le 31 mars
les alliés entre dans paris le tsar
alexandre à la tête de ses troupes se
dirigent vers la place de la concorde où
le rejoint le roi de prusse à la tête de
ses troupes est aussi schwarzenberg et
les autrichiens quentin maubreuil et
bien maubreuil là c'est trouver tout à
coup alors plus royaliste qui ne l'a
jamais été et avec quelques monarchiste
ultra il servait à cheval sur la place
vendôme et l'a d'ailleurs il avait fait
quelque chose que pas extrêmement mal
hein ils avaient attaché sa légion
d'honneur à la queue de son cheval ne
trouvais ça très bien mais là avec ces
jeunes gens il a voulu faire tomber
faire chuter la statue de napoléon qui
est en haut de la colonne vendôme on
lave s'est attelée une corde on a
d'ailleurs réussi rien du tout c'était
très bien boulonné c'était très bien
vissé et on n'a pas réussi à faire
tomber le statut n'a pris mais le pli
était pris maubreuil avait rencontré des
royalistes de son âge de sa génération
aussi ultra que lui il y avait des
réunions clandestines dans paris on
voulait le roi et maubreuil dans ces
réunions parler plus fort que tu es le
roi qu'elle aura mal oui 18 naturel
celui qui était en exil depuis si
longtemps
celui qui avait quitté la france le jour
même où louis saez essayé de partir pour
varennes et louis saez lui se faisait
arrêter mais pas le comte de provence il
était en exil se déclarait louis xviii
et attendait patiemment leur entrée en
france
pouvait-il en attente c'était tout le
problème justement qui se posaient à
monsieur le talent or il allait advenir
monsieur de talent qui attendait cette
heure-là en se disant qu'elle allait
sonner ce sont leurs propres ils
allaient arriver à monsieur le talent
quelque chose à quoi il ne s'attendait
pas c'est que le tsar alexandre en
quittant la place de la concorde
n'avaient eu que quelques pas à faire
pour aller à côté rue saint florentin
justement où habitait ses talents dans
ce superbe hôtel le tsar alexandre était
venu demander l'hospitalité à monsieur
talent et c'est là dans cet hôtel de la
rue saint florentin que le destin de la
france elle et se joue qu'à un étage se
trouvait talent avec le gouvernement
provisoire qu'il allait constituer l
étage supérieur se trouvait le tsar
alexandre avec ses ministres et sa suite
et les deux hommes se rencontrent et
alran lui propose une solution
la peau les os abdiquera mais il
abdiquera en faveur du roi drame son
fils c'est une solution qui plaît
beaucoup et ce talent et pas seulement à
lui parce que au fond les bourbons s'ils
reviennent on sait pas très bien ce
qu'ils voudront et que deviendra le
personnel qui s'est créé le au personnel
qui s'est créé une situation
exceptionnelle au long de la révolution
et de l'empiré tandis que le roi de rome
bien fatalement c'est l'utilisation de
ce même personnel à commencer par
monsieur talent à lui-même le roi de
rome mais tout enfant mais il y aura une
régence de monsieur talent se voit très
bien sinon région lui même tout - chef
du gouvernement de cette région
malheureusement le tsar alexandre n'est
pas convaincu il a été forte irrité par
la polaire et cette irritation se
reportent
sa famille est dans les premières
réunions il dit n'ont pas droit dans mes
talents se dit toujours tout de même
qu'il y a derrière l'empereur d'autriche
qui est le grand père et le grand-père
et le petit roi de rome tout même
pourrait régner parce qu'il est
justement le petit-fils de ce grand père
ce qui va se passer dans les quelques
jours qui se déroule alors c'est
précisément laventure de mauroy parce
que talleyrand l'adie l'a écrit à la
duchesse de courant ce qui gêne c'est
que napoléon soit vivant et oui s'il
abdique en faveur du roi droit eh bien
il sera là quand même
il sera dans un château et même s'il est
à l'étranger l'autre peut revenir quand
dans un mois dans un an avec cet homme
là on peut s'attendre à tout c'est vrai
en revanche s'il était mort et talent
l'a écrit à madame de courlande s'il
était tué
la situation serait beaucoup plus fort
il est là lui il est à fontainebleau
il est à fontainebleau il y a une armée
il pense encore reprendre la situation
en main ils pensent attaqué paris en
chasser les alliés ils pensent qu'ils
ont dégarni les collines autour de paris
qu'ils ont commis des imprudences il est
là il croit encore pouvoir gagner la
partie et on l'apprend à paris qu'il est
on apprend à paris qu'il va attaquer et
justement ce qu'ils sont en train de
manoeuvrer les royalistes d'une part
ceux qui sont pour la régence d'autres
pas personne ne veut napoléon et c'est
pourquoi le 3 avril mme aubry reçoit à
ces trois domiciles des billets
assistant de monsieur roux laborie
l'agent de talent
roux laborie l'âme damnée le talent
celui qui est la rue saint florentin et
qui lui écrit venez venez venez venez
tout
venez à l'instant ce n'est que le soin
comme au breuil a trouvé ces billets ça
n'est que le square comme au breuil à
kourou saint florentin et là il faut
imaginer maubreuil arrivant dans la nuit
montans d'admirables escalier qui le
conduit vers son destin roule à bord il
atteint avez-vous dîner non aller dîner
parce que ce que j'ai à vous dire est
trop grave
vous ne pouvez pas l'entendre le ventre
vide et mogwai valider une heure et
demie après il revient à essayer vous
êtes vous un homme courageux je le crois
de moguai êtes vous disposé à servir le
roi et pour cela à courir des risques
inouïs
je le crois du ma voix je suis prêt
voilà ce qu'il faut c'est la roue
laborie hésite ce qu'il faut c'est tuer
la volée imaginez maubreuil qui ont tant
cela tu es napoléon comment oui il nous
gêne on vous donnera sans tain écoutez
demo brouille tuer la pole et non dans
une bataille je veux bien dans la guerre
mais pas au coin d'un bois je ne suis
pas un brigand vous serez duc vous aurez
deux cent mille livres de rente
alors mon bras et réfléchi
écoutez sans tom c'est trop 12 me
suffisent il faudra qu'il soit vécue
vêtus d'uniformes de la gamme très bien
ce sera fait par tes commencé à recruter
vos hommes venaient prendre mes ordres
mais vous serez prêt et dans la nuit
maubreuil commençons l'action il prend
d'abord un lieutenant qui est incertain
d'asie qui le suivra dans toutes ses
aventures et il vient rendre compte à
l'aube du 4 qu'il est prêt à temps
d'aimer ordre dire ou la mort il faut
dans les faire tendre césar parce que le
4 le destin de la france tourne entre
leucate
napoléon a été forcé à midi par ses
maréchaux à fontainebleau d'abdiquer on
lui a dit abdiqué maintenant vous sauver
le roi de rome abdiquer en faveur du roi
de rome il abdiquer en faveur du roi
d'euros et les maréchaux n'est
mcdonald's et caulaincourt sont arrivés
à paris ont vu le tsar le soir du 4 et
toute cette journée du 4 on attend
suivant la décision qui va être prise
par le tsar on tuera ou non la polaire
et l'homme et la hem au breuil et là il
attend qu'il est prêt à tuer la pole et
à 2 heures du matin le tsar ayant reçu
les maréchaux et presque convaincu on
lui a dit mais si le roi de rome c'est
la vraie solution les bourbons ne sont
rien pour les français et puis l'armée
et dévoué à napoléon l'armée suit
napoléon
si vous le voulez plus de guerre adopter
cette solution et il est tout près il va
le faire à deux heures du matin à l'aide
de camp se présente présente une dépêche
haute ça sur cette dépêche
il ya simplement quelques îles le
maréchal marmont vient de passer avec
son armée dans les lignes russes et
l'artsakh frappe sur la table messieurs
vous m'avez tromper l'armée n'est pas
fidèle à napoléon
ce que je veux c'est une abdication à
conditionner les maréchaux repartiront
pour fontainebleau
exigeront le lendemain cette abdication
de napoléon c'était le 5 et le 6 au
matin
napoléon signera cette seconde boutique
or pendant tout ce temps maubreuil
littéralement tenue sous pression il est
en réserve
il est là il est prêt à partir mais le 5
s'est finie on n'a plus besoin lui les
jeux sont faits napoléon abdiqué
définitivement il s'organise tout roule
à bord et dira simplement à beaubreuil
le prince de talleyrand est au courant
de tout le prince de talleyrand vous
remercie vous serez récompensés comme si
vous aviez âge mais voilà les jours
passent le conteneur d'artois arrive on
crée le premier gouvernement non plus 18
les récompenses pleuvent sur tout le
monde sauf sur maubreuil et vaudreuil
attendri maubreuil assiègent les
antichambres dit enfin et mois de 16
on lui donne non pas une récompense mais
une mission et cette mission est forte
extraordinaire cette mission
on ne sait pas si on lit les documents
ce qu'elle est en réalité mais les
documents sont incroyables c'est le
ministre de la guerre c'est le directeur
des postes c'est miss de la police qui
disent monsieur de maubreuil peut à tout
moment et quand il le voudra
réquisitionné toutes les forces armées
de france pour le service d'une mission
qui lui est confiée quelle mission
frédérick masson un grand historien a
cru qu'il s'agissait toujours de tuer la
peau les os qui à ce moment-là descendez
vers l'île d'elle mais maurice garçon
autres grands historiens grand avocat et
grand historien il fut mon ami maurice
garçon qui a entièrement repris la ferme
au breuil à la lumière de documents
inédits elle dit que justement le fait
qu'on les donnait ses ordres de missions
fantastique à maubreuil prouver que ce
n'était pas pour tuer la peau les os car
ses ordres la rue on les donne
verbalement
on ne donne pas des documents imaginer
qu'il ait vraiment eu et napoléon y en
aurait trouvé sur lui tous ses ordres
impossible la vérité était comment
breuil s'était fait fort de ramener à
paris une partie du trésor de napoléon
qu'on avait perdu et oui qu'on avait
perdu sur les routes et ça suffisait
pour qu'on lui donne justement ces
ordres de mission même au breuil avait
une autre idée
il savait que la reine catherine de vue
rimbert était parti rejoindre son mari
des gens suisse jérôme elle était partie
avec toute sa fortune
une suite de six voitures 11 caisses
dans ces voitures remplies d'or et de
bijoux émaux breuil avait décidé tout
simplement de réquisitionner
cette forte et le 21 à fossard après
montereau sur la route de suisse il
barre avec un détachement militaire la
route s'empare des bijoux et des gains
et deux lors de la reine catherine qui
pleure mais qui n'en peut mais ramène le
tout à paris mais entre temps il
s'arrête dans une berge dans cette
auberge
il fait monter les caisses il a avec lui
une norme valley de cuir ce qu'on
appelait une vache qui est très vite
quand il est dans la quand il monte dans
la champ et il a les clés des caisses ce
qu'il fait on ne sait pas mais un peu
plus tard il fait redescendre les
caisses dans la voiture dans sa voiture
il redescend avec la vache mais alors il
est très très très lourde
les quais seront déposés chez le comte
d'artois et vitrolles devenu ministre
depuis peu recevra ce moment là ne dit
attribuer pouvant table donné celle
rhodes le ministre dit ça et le tsar
fait savoir qu'il est très mécontent
parce que catherine de woerth abers et
sa cousine germaine comment s'en prend à
la fortune aux biens de sa cousine
germaine qu'on retrouve cette fortune
immédiatement qu on la range et qu'on
punisse le coupable alors vitrolles
convoque maubreuil qui arrivent et qui
le prend de très haut qui dit mais enfin
j'ai eu la mission de récupérer les
biens de napoléon j'ai cru que c'étaient
les biad de la france que cette femme
emportée j'ai fait moins de voix et vous
avez lors il est là vous avez les
caisses et bien dit roland va les ouvrir
ses caisses on les ouvre
et la plupart sont vides et oui il ya là
les grands écrans aux armes de
westphalie les bijoux de la reine
catherine et dans ses écrits n'y a plus
rien fureur de vitrolles qui invective
maubreuil et maubreuil qui le prend de
très très haut maubreuil qui dit
simplement monsieur le ministre je vous
en prie par ce ton là avec moi ah mais
non vous ne savez pas qui vous parlez
comment je ne sais pas qui vous barrent
l'api je parle
comment je m'appelle maubreuil et c'est
moi que monsieur de talent a chargé
d'assassiner napoléon sont des
situations très embêtant pour un
ministre extrêmement inconfortable huit
ans elle était au courant de rien mais
il comprend que c'est très possible
puisqu'il laisse partir nombre on
arrêtera quand même quelques quelques
jours plus tard quant aux bijoux en
découvrira que domestiques de maubreuil
les as en sable et sur la rive de la
seine ce qui quand même cash est un peu
curieux sont les a presque tous
retrouvés on les a rendus à l'arène de
westphalie qui a pu rejoindre son cher
jérôme en suisse est membre eux mêmes au
breuil il est en prison et il y serait
pour longtemps si napoléon n'était pas
venu dilemme c'est une époque difficile
à vivre avouez le
alors louis xviii avant de partir donne
l'ordre d'élargir maubreuil parce
qu'enfin cet homme qui devait tuer
napoléon si napoléon arrive et le trouve
en prison même pas très bien pour moi et
on le libère manque de chance il est
pris par la police de napoléon on va
instruire son procès un grand procès qui
va accabler les bourbons d'infamie il
s'évade on le reprendra plus tard sous
louis xviii
on le jugera il restera assez longtemps
en prison
en prison il en sortira il en sortira et
ce sera en 1827 la scène que je vous ai
raconté ce sera en 1827 hassani la gifle
ce sera le prince des talents abattue
sur le sol ce sera également une
éclosion de brochures autour de ce
souffle et l'histoire du soufflet
théorie du souffle et il y aura même une
brochure qui disait de l'indifférence en
matière de souffler scud pas très très
gentil beau talent mais là aussi du
breuil une fois de plus sera condamné à
faire de la prison
il en sortira on en sort toujours et il
est très très amer disons qu'on ne peut
pas le plaindre parce que cet homme qui
s'était transporte néant voleur de grand
chemin n'est pas très à plein mais
disons aussi que quand même on n'a pas
été très gentil pour lui parce qu'enfin
quoi c'est pas lui qui avait proposé de
tuer la peau les os c'était les autres
et tout ce qui lui était arrivé c'était
à cause de cette idée qui avait germé un
jour dans la cervelle de monsieur talons
sous louis-philippe maubreuil assiègent
délégation de russie d'autriche de
prusse de lettre en disant comment et
des mois euh j'ai voulu rendre service
et j'ai été victime d'une grande
injustice je demande des secours à la
fin les pays étrangers sont furieux
réclame auprès de louis philippe et qui
pour faire terme au bail lui donne une
pension de 5000 francs par mais
savez-vous le plus incroyable c'est
qu'après louis philippe et à napoléon
iii
oui le neveu de l'autre et napoléon iii
veut qu'une immense bienveillance va
reconduire la pension que louis-philippe
verser à mme aubry
et sous le règne de napoléon iii
monsieur de maubreuil qui avait voulu
tuer napoléon touchera une pension du
neveu de celui qu'ils étaient chargés
d'assassiner à 82 ans il se marie
pourquoi pas l'élu est une charmante
personne beaucoup plus jeune que lui qui
a 15 ans elle était fille d'un cocher de
fiacre est partie de chez elle
dix ans plus tard elle était
millionnaire millionnaire en or de
l'époque
il faut dire qu'elle demandait 75 mille
francs pour un petit moment qu'ils
étaient de même extrêmement bien payé on
comprend qu'elle soit devenue très
rapidement millionnaire mais revel avait
soif d'honorabilité et elle a demandé au
marquis de maubreuil de lui donner sans
ce qu'il a fait immédiatement il a
touché pour sa trente mille francs
elle était marquée il avait 39 il est
mort en 1869 et à son cortège funèbre
il y aura un détachement de l'armée qui
rendra les honneurs
non pas parce qu'il avait voulu tuer
napoléon mais parce que il était
chevalier de la légion d'honneur
[Musique]